salut tout le monde si vous voulez louer
le studio sf pour faire votre propre
podcasts ou pour objet d la qualité de
votre podcast c'est possible écrivez
nous à sans filtre podcast at gmail.com
vous venez ici le service et tout
compris vous avez la vidéo vous avez le
son qu'on vous donne suite après votre
enregistrement
yann nicol qui va être là pour vous
servez pour vous accompagner dans cette
aventure
le studio sfr on s'assure que la qualité
était petit mal à tous les niveaux et
puis pour ramener votre projet le haut
niveau c'est vraiment la bonne chose à
faire alors écrivez-nous savoir plaisir
de vous recevoir ici une production du f
[Musique]
bienvenue au sans filtre le podcast où
on parle de ce qu'on veut avec nos
invités date c'est super quand tu es
avec moi de me plante aujourd'hui
daumier pas là pour l'intro est en
vacances aux îles de la madeleine
le podcast cette semaine et présenté par
notre page pétrone sur notre page p tuer
on en a pris l'habitude de faire après
chaque podcast un petit segment qu'on
appelle avec encore moins de filtres ou
encore moins de filtres ou pas de filtre
on ne sait pas exactement c'est moi qui
s'appelle comment mais dans le fond ce
qu'on fait c'est qu'on parle de moi
nicole on parle un petit peu la
conversation qu'on m'aide à voir donc on
approfondit nos réflexions on discute de
nos impressions de des points qui nous
ont fait cheminer dans la conversation
avec l'invité donc c'est vraiment une
occasion de débriefer du podcast de
relaxer des fonds sur une petite bière
on fait juste il est un fait que si vous
voulez avoir accès à ce contenu exclusif
la dirigez vous vers notre page pétri en
le lien va être dans la description du
podcast c'est également la meilleure
façon de nous encourager
sinon cette semaine ont reçu adib
alkhalidey ça fait longtemps qu'on veut
avoir à dire sur le podcast 6 1 aux
invités du temps en tête de liste on
s'écrit on se répond ça donnait jamais
finalement la sallaz à donner à dit bhl
qui évidemment est un humoriste très
connu mais qui a également une histoire
extraordinaire son père a quitté son
pays natal en temps de guerre fait le
tour de l'europe il rencontré la mère
d'adeeb au maroc ils sont déplacés par
ce qui est épars d'avoir des papiers ils
sont revenus en amérique sont ils sont
venus en amérique en fête et sont
installés à montréal nord et là a dit
elle nous raconte un petit peu comme
insolites et son enfance qu'est ce qui
l'a mené vers l'humour quels ont été les
moments marquants ou est ce qu'ils
réalisent et que les os qui a réalisé
qu'ils étaient différents des autres en
fait une conversation passionnante on a
parlé pendant long segment de caisse qui
était le beau jusqu'au raiman le bon et
allez un petit peu dans la philosophie a
dit petit juste en parlant et drôle tu
réalises rapidement pourquoi ils succès
qu'il ya c'est vraiment une personne un
bon vivant une rencontre extraordinaire
honnêtement avec avec un homme qui l'est
tout autant donc participer aux
conversations laisser des commentaires
écrivez vos impressions de ski a dit de
nous raconter également les six nuls et
europe dating abonnez vous à nos chaînes
vous connaissez le tralala
mais principalement en fait profiter de
cette conversation le fait que bon
écoutez bompas de castres
[Musique]
yes
alors bienvenue mais merci les gars de
non recevoir
ça fait quand même un bout de temps
qu'on ou moins depuis que j'ai écouté le
le poker qui était plus fort avec thomas
levac silva rejoint ainsi juan
puis j'ai entendu je sais pas pourquoi
l'autre jour je me pose la question
pourquoi j'aime les potes que j'aime
vraiment les podcasts je trouve vraiment
que c'est gémonies m'apprend gens
consomment beaucoup je pense à ça a
changé le monde était vraiment cessé
j'ai entendu un gars dire que c'était
l'équivalent de de l'invention de
l'imprimerie pour le roy responsable ce
qui faisait pour la première fois le
monde peuvent gens faire quelque chose
ni s'instruire en même temps et écoutez
si on dit qu'on est dans une société où
il ya plus de deux ans en chine span
comme les gens ils sont tous cas de se
concentrer
mais qu'est-ce tout le monde écoute des
podcasts qui dure 2 heures 3 a su
cependant le souhaitent à vaisselle
temps mais n'a jeté dans l'auto c'est le
fun mais moi je parle j'en fais beaucoup
jugent pas j'aime parler vu man mais il
va falloir que j'arrête de vous êtes
peut-être parmi les derniers sites à
l'irrigation
d'ailleurs c'est pas de calais je pense
c'est moi qui tu l as assuré là mais je
les réécoute état aujourd'hui acheter ma
forme de toupie lice en quittant compte
que tu a compté sept journées le son
sont incroyables
j'ai tout oublié on retient toute leur
passé mais on a invité les gens à
l'écouté je ne mange pas 14 qui te
raconte l'histoire de ton père toit est
passé pourquoi italien est arrivé ici en
fait moi c'est fascinant
surtout dans un climat comme
actuellement mouais
je trouve que ça mais tellement lumière
le courage moi des gens qui viennent ici
toilettes leur pays qu'ils viennent ici
je trouve c'est facile mais même moi je
savais pas ça tu en prends c'est comme
ça mais ça m'a saisi moi parce que tu es
je pense moi je pense j'ai pas un
parcours d'immigrants typique parce que
nous on n'a pas vraiment eu de lien avec
la famille en irak de mon père parce que
le téléphone était coupé comme mon père
est quelqu'un qui a fui le régime de
saddam hussein ils pouvaient pim ça
m'était sa famille en danger si on
rentre en contact avec eux fake c'est
quand j'ai pas vraiment de femmes
j'ai de la famille là-bas mais je
connais pas léger j'ai rencontré un
cousin dans donne en 32 ans d'existence
d'affecter j'ai pas la majorité des
immigrants ont beaucoup de contacts avec
leurs familles quand même dans leurs
pays respectifs
moi j'avais juste des contacts avec le
côté de ma mère effectif tout mon mon
rapport à l'immigration est sage et
sature été un peu mélangeant pour moi
depuis tout petit mais dans les
dernières années j'ai parce que mon père
ait décidé j'ai posé plein de questions
je voulais ça c'est fort kent importante
et quand quand un membre de ta famille
qui s'en va il part avec des histoires
entier les êtres humains on vient tous
une fois sur terre on vit des affaires
tout le monde a une histoire forte top
quand tu poses des questions à quelqu'un
n'importe qui qui se rend compte dans la
rue il a une histoire que selon lui est
pas intéressante mais que toi tu veux
vraiment y mais moi j'ai vécu avec mon
père moi je veux mon père y avait rien
d'intéressant pour moi donc je le
connaissais été mais je suis rentré dans
des affaires puis je sentais que lui lui
ammann et m'a même dit on m'a jamais
posé des questions sur comment je suis
ni il se rappelait ça lui a fait du bien
de se rappeler de moore âge que celui a
pris devenir pis si c'est vraiment
l'histoire classique l'a 75 dollars dans
les poches
il ya tout vendu puis mon père est parti
de l'irak au maroc
il s'installe confié pas dépasser par
l'europe
tant qu'un fuyard gély toute la fura
régime dictatorial passe par paris
le genre de job puis là après italie
s'installer au maroc puis au maroc comme
ma soeur et moi on n'est ni on est mangé
deux soeurs la mema ma grande soeur et
nous marchons chine au maroc puis le
gouvernement marocain dit à mes parents
que parce que mon père était la clé on
aurait jamais de papier fait là il ya
comme il ya vendu avait une petite
librairie l'a vendu sa librairie était
professeur dans une école
je pense que c'était vraiment et la
petite école première année chose de
même pis on vivait dans un petit village
dans le désert c'était vraiment une vie
c'est les gens qui s'imaginent que tout
le monde qu'ils quittent parce que
j'aurai crever la dalle ou sepa
différement ça des fois c'est juste une
petite vie métier nous dans notre cas on
n'avait pas de papiers on aurait jamais
eu un mais quand tu y penses à sale
impossible avouez que ça prend du temps
avant mon mais même moi ça me prend un
peu de temps avant de faire ici comment
j'aurais vécu une vie sans papiers et
jump est un citoyen ou de rien ouais tu
as quelque chose je demande le pocket la
vague parce qu'il ya des gens qui sont
fâchés
ouais contre les immigrants illégaux qui
aurait alors passé ils n'ont pas de
papiers mais c'est le prix à la base
n'ont pas de papiers puis le pire c'est
que s'ils retournent chez eux
mettez ça c'est comme si good c'est
l'oeil c'est le gros le groupe clivage
qui a chez les gens mais tant qu'ils
sont défavorables à l'immigration
c'est qu'ils ont vraiment l'impression
que quand quelqu'un vient ici il va
vivre aux crochets de l'étape c'est
d'état qui doit se
mais comme je sais pas avec qui ces gens
là on chili mais moi tous les immigrants
que je connais ils viennent ici puis la
première obsession qui on sait
travailler et mes enfants vont devenir
des diplômes universitaires
c'est comme les deux traits extrêmement
dominant dans la culture migrants et le
téf et je sais pas comme douce et jean
laporte l'espèce de l'est vivent aux
crochets de la m mais les taxistes avec
mes textes
non non c'est gala il vient contribuer
c'est qu'ils embauchent les avais dit
s'il y avait des immigrés ils sont sept
des leurs il serait que jean nos parents
même si on n'était pas bon à l'école ou
si on écoutait pas au dessus des
affaires de même c'est comme c'était dur
là pour nous et on a mis des 10 secondes
j'ai quitté mon pays pour que tu ailles
allait coûter jusqu'à un viol j'ai coulé
l'examen de fractions ratés comme si je
t'attrape avec de la drogue je t'envoie
traire des moutons au maroc ses jambes
de ce genre de menace c'est pas et
j'avais genre disant gw en mer des
moutons je n'aime pas qu'on pouvait
faire des moutons j'apprends cette
affaire on est pas mal et les domaines
non ça c'est plus du pire je savais que
c'était pas vrai j'avais dans les urnes
a marché comme à la des contacts de
caton débutant avant de m'envoyer génère
des fois qu'il mouton fait que non on
essayait de ça je pense les gens iront
comme un muscle inception avec
l'immigration parce que je pense les
québec en général il ya quelque chose
que j'étais comme c'est drôle parce que
le 7 c'est drôle parce que chez chaque
saint jean il ya comme un scandale y
accueillait comme tout à une affaire moi
je suis persuadé que les moyens d'un
point de vue très très très reculées
avec beaucoup beaucoup de perspectives
pendant le pas dans le détail mais avec
beaucoup de perspectives tous les êtres
humains sont des immigrants à un degré
différent
tout le monde est arrivé quelque part à
un moment ou un autre puis c'est juste
la force de d'être en interaction avec
l'écosystème dans lequel tu vis la
nature la température tout ça il y a des
traits de culture qui se développent et
ça te donne l'impression que c'est chez
toi c'est normal tu es mais tout le
monde est arrivé quelques paramètres si
tu regarde l'histoire de l'humanité les
pubs bouge sans arrêt mais ça en dirait
qu'il ya personne qui veut
il ya personne qui veut sortir sa tête
la tête de son cabinet on sait que c'est
normal que les peuples bouge on est
africain dans l'ouest y retourna au
départ et s'est senti mal puisqu'il
faisait ça c'est comme l'y appelait seul
croissants dorés ou est ce que doit ce
qui est apparemment tout le monde mon
bien tout le monde viendrait de tubes
le ca s'est éparpillé de c'est surtout
rn 10 même si ici le 1 ou québec le
tilelli les européens ou les occidentaux
sont arrivés si ça fait pas si longtemps
que non dit que ça ne fait vraiment pas
si longtemps que pour penser qu'on n'est
pas immigrants lille ouais c'est combien
de générations aussi je veux dire c'est
pas ces postes au total génération qui
n'aura pas dit quasiment sans attendre
le c400 c'est juste quatre fois cette
saison va pas de temps c'est quatre
grands pères potentiels 4,5
peut-être parce que l'espérance de vie
ça bouge un peu mais mettez s'adresse à
quelque pas ça reste tapie je sais pas
il ya quelque chose il ya quelque chose
au québec
des fois j'ai des fois j'ai peur moi
j'ai peur de vous ça s'en va parce que
j'ai à cause de la pandémie j'ai
recommencé à lire la peste d'albert
beaucoup de monde sont retombés dans
leur job en discussion bernard massard
date de ces jeunes mais moi aussi je me
rappelle de rien lui albert camus ces
genres pour moi c'est comme si mon top
mais je me rappelle pas du dif d'élus
trop jeune je me dis pourquoi ils me
font lire des livres bon comme ça j'ai
l'impression vie notre vie en ayant
l'impression qu'on lui on le lui a pas
été obligée tu avais 17 ans les a faites
sans de niaiseries jarret à la radio
étudiante là qui lie la peste à la règle
et edwina synopsis sur internet pour
répondre de tes amis tu ont aidé avec
leurs notes de course pas c'est pas mal
géré la presse puis comme dès le début
iliad était un rat de remords trois
rameurs après ça j'en ris contient deux
journées assimilera m'a dit c'est tout
le monde au début fait juste dire ça va
aller ça va aller c'est correct ça va
passer ça va passer où il y en a qui
vont faire assez dégueulasse mais ça va
passer
puis j'ai l'impression que c'est la même
chose avec tous les commentaires
racistes que je vois
internet j'ai l'impression que c'est
comme des petits rats morts les spas les
gens des commentaires que tu fais genre
s'est trouvé dégueulasse cesti ce que je
viens de lire mais il y en a pas tant
que ça va passer mais finalement ce type
quand comptabilisés comme ou est-ce que
ça s'envole tout ça c'est une femme
battue une maladie de société qu'on va
devoir comme on va devoir avant une
réelle conversation là-dessus puisse
dire comme c'est pas c'est pas une vie
que tu veux pour aucun être humain peut
être que tu es enfant tu veux pas une
vie tu veux pas une vie pour tes enfants
ou l'autre est synonyme de de deux
guerres de conflits this way au québec
vieillit ça c'est juste en tout genre et
et after its des commentaires qui
avaient par rapport à dominique anglade
le psy qui ajuste du monde à mettre
l'art massa même le rapport avec ce soit
des raciale martonas ton pays dans la
nappe noire insultes vraiment horrible
basée sur la race et tu dis qu'il ya
encore du chemin faille encore du monde
qu'ils pensent de même ça mais c'est ça
le problème c'est que la télé y avait
les grosses compagnies décident de
boycotter facebook
pointant que leur traitement des
commentaires et ne sera pas un haut
niveau
mais même ceux - je te veux je peux
d'enlever le tapis phi phi de plastal
babu qui en disent tapis pour cacher
c'est parce que au final de censurer des
gens qui ont des commentaires haineux
yao j'espère que dans leur cercle intime
nous à entretenir ses ils vont continuer
à élever leurs enfants quand ils vont
continuer à monter
au lieu d'avoir une diction jeu mais en
fait c'était situe comme un cul de sac
on dirait la situation la même et tu
vois qu'il ya eu beaucoup de progrès par
rapport à l'homophobie
quand même là je sais qu'il ya beaucoup
de travail à faire mais mais moi quand
j'étais jeune c'était normal d'être
ouvertement homophobe puis j'entendais
des adultes les bains il m'aime moi dans
mon langage faut que j'me tchèque parce
que j'ai encore des os line qui
paraissait bengee sebag et cela quel
point était normalisé humeur un point
dans un domaine du sport à quel point de
prêter l'autre personne de fifre quelque
chose qui était genre t'as pas été
très sincèrement c'est quelque chose qui
était super accepter qu'il a maintenant
les gens vont illustrer les gens vont
moins le faire maintenant parce que tu
veux pas être le gars dans le vestiaire
qui dit quelque chose puisqu'elle ya
quatre personnes qui sont là ça va le
moins disant pas avec ça on peut on peut
nier zay puis mais comme tu peux pas
juste et leur en fait il ya comme une
forme de j'ai l'impression que quand
l'individu se sent rejetée par le groupe
pour son comportement et a tendance à se
remettre en question mais je dis pas que
je dis pas que l'exercice est de rejeter
les gens mais moi ce que j'aime est
tendu tout ce qu'on a vécu récemment du
black light marquis pour moi et comme le
porte étendard de toutes les luttes
c'est à dire que si la cause des noirs
avancent tous les autres
toutes les autres favorites de minorités
ou de personnes si on veut dans des
situations opprimés vont en bénéficier
parce que si ce test une lutte qui dure
depuis tellement longtemps puis moi ce
que j'ai aimé de ce mouvement là ces
derniers temps c'est de voir des
québécois de souche des québécois blancs
vraiment prendre la parole puis partager
des affaires puis tout parce que ça plus
d'impact que si c'est moi moi le monde
qui viennent écouter ils sont déjà
vendus à la différence je suis différent
entre comprend fécamp quand tu vois des
ben j'sais pas d'aider les influenceurs
des gens qui s'adresse vraiment plus
commune une masse populaire faire ça moi
je suis persuadé que ça ait du que le
monde
ça les rend moins mal à l'aise de se
tenir debout puis dire c'est comme un
souper de noël ski canadien que c'est
qu'enfin une joke racistes ou homophobes
ou à rêver non parfois ça drôle de ce
type comme moi je trouve que c'est j'ai
des amis j'étais en train de devenir
nisy du monde ou à avoir de la haine
envers du monde que moi j'aime t il faut
c'est la seule manière de faire avancer
le truc c'est nous dans le cercle intime
de dieu puis moi j'ai dû faire ça dans
ma famille parce que moi je pense que la
prochaine étape après que ce genre de
combat là soient livrés c'est que les
fils fille dit
grand se retournent vers leurs parents
leur communauté 10la vous nous laissez
des québécois lé là vous nous laissez
devenir 100 % des québécois comme on va
honorer nos racines
mais on est des québécois on est on vit
ici parce qu'il ya quand même bien plus
efficacement un double
ouais comme entre deux parce que d'un
côté mais ce que j'attendais justement
dire dans d'autres cas c'est que d'un
côté ci dessus et assimile trop c'est
mal vu dans le communautaire pied
c'est stupide parce que c'est juste une
question de temps un logis trente deux
ans avec je le vois c'est une question
de temps avant que tu réalises que tout
ce qu'ils jugeaient eux aussi s'assimile
autant que toi c'est juste stick le
jugement ça c'est chaque mois chaque
fois que je juge quelqu'un et de
quelques jours plus tard je réalise que
mon jugement m'a empêché d'être curieux
hockey face à ce que je jugeais vais-je
aïssa mais je juge moi je dis pas que
juste moi je vois des affaires je
réalise c'est la même chose dans nos
communautés on juge des affaires on se
ferme à la curiosité puis quelques
années plus tard tu croises la personne
qu'il jugeait pts et cambio tu fais ce
que tu me disais que je voulais pas
faire ça demande du courage quand
migrants de venir à québécois parce
qu'elle souvent tu es seul surtout quand
comme moi dans ma famille j'étais dans
la communauté j'étais comme le petit
rebelle comme celui qui voulait vivre
une vie à sa manière sans nécessairement
sans nécessairement avoir des comptes à
rendre à ma communauté
d'un autre côté s'est arrêté quand même
facile pour moi parce que ma vie était
différente de tous les immigrants avec
qui je te le dis mes parents sont
divorcés
j'ai pas de tiges et pas j'ai pas de
famille on nous obligeait pas aller dans
les gares de ring
religieux tout ça comme nous j'ai pas
tant des liens d'appartenance
comme j'ai des amis qui en ont avec leur
communauté
mais j'en ai un de coeur puis j'en ai un
de culture dans le sens où j'ai grandi
avec des arabes principalement dans mon
quartier à ville saint-laurent dans le
nord de la ville où moi j'ai gardé
grandi dans un cas d'un chef
un quartier qui s'appelle cham hollande
c'est comme ça que les gens appelaient
notre quartier chameau y avait juste des
arabes et des noirs
non mais y avait des blancs aussi avait
un et moi c'est ça que c'est pour ça
qu'il est logique
moi j'étais fasciné parce que quand je
suis sortie de de mon quartier je t'ai
détruits - quand j'arrivais au cégep
j'étais détruite pour la première fois
de ma vie
il n'y avait pas des noirs des blancs
des arabes des chinois des mois j'ai
grandi dans un quartier avait de tout
pour ouvrir et de toutes les classes
sociales avait déjà super riches
il y avait des mares eu à ville
saint-laurent moi j'habitais dans un
espèce de comme un espèce de citer
d'immeubles comme plein de gros blocs
mais en face de chez moi c'est du monde
qui avait des duplex pire des belles
maisons en pis si c'était pas le genre
de quartier où il y avait juste des
sites et injuste des espèces des hlm
fait que j'ai grandi nous on n'a jamais
senti l'écart pauvres riches ou la
couleur de peau
g en grandissant là c'est pas quelque
chose j'ai senti pour moi j'étais normal
dans mon quartier vraiment là c'est
quand je suis sorti de mon quartier au
cégep
j'arrive ans est allé interview au au
cégep saint-laurent cinéma et
communication bi j'arrive puis je suis
le seul immigrants du programme puis là
je regarde autour de moi et je te jure
comme ça aurait des années avant de
comprendre le traumatisme de la solitude
de fatum genre tout le monde vient de
saint jean sont riches et si comme moi
je m étais là jusqu'au chic c'est un
monde de différence l'entente le glas de
ville saint laurent qui a grandi avec
toutes les cultures même à mon école
secondaire il y avait de tout le
vraiment il y avait quand je dis de tous
et c'est comme même avec une bonne
proportion ne sais pas j'ai grandi dans
un dent
de 8 à 15 titres qu'on quitte le
secondaire 700g gras de 8 à 16 ans dans
un monde vraiment là ça ressemble à
l'onu le tc comme du monde de partout
puis avec moi c'était ma c'était ma
conception du monde
pour moi c'était ça le monde mais après
quand j'arrivais dans le monde des
adultes là j'ai découvert autre chose
puis dans le milieu artistique la même
chose j'arrive et puis comme j'étais le
seul migrants piles et quelques migrants
qui étaient là j'ai pas eu de contact
avec eux ça a pris dix années avant
qu'ils auront réussi ça à se parler puis
même lance pas tout et aux papilles
serment tout intéressé les bancs d'école
tétouan tout il remarquer justement
c'était ce clash et cette différence
mais ce que les gens tels faisait sentir
et où est-ce qui est ce que les gens de
considérer percevait différemment des
autres sur les bancs d'école te dire au
sujet de ton nom je pense que les gens
étaient comme outil comme je pense fille
comme ça se passe pas de manière
consciente et mettons que mettons que tu
as grandi dans un quartier où comme tout
le monde et blanc il a tu arrives au
sujet picom est un gars qui a grandi
dans un quartier où comme ça parle un
peu différemment savoie le monde un peu
différemment c'est un petit à petit tu
vas pas sentir que vous avez des choses
en commun sous tu veux juste peut-être
différent neutre indifférent moi j'ai
pas senti de gens ont-ils pas écrit
parce qu'il m'aime moi j'ai pu sentir
déjà angérien en commande évident da par
an comment tu fais pour deep qui
montrait que ta vraie personnalité quand
il commet pleine quête identitaire de
2,71 au cégep écoles qu'est ce qui
m'attend moi je me suis beaucoup
réfugier dans la radio étudiante avec
avec avec mes amis dit je me suis fait
des amis tout des espèces de outside du
système d'aidé des gens peu à l'écart et
je me suis créé comme une espèce de
communauté qui ressemble à mon école
secondaire du monde de toutes les
cultures métier moi mes meilleures amies
j'ai des meilleurs amis qui sont
québécois de souche
j'ai des amis qui sont à d'origine
haïtienne libanaise
j'ai un beau père qui vietnamien
c'est comme j'ai vraiment chi tellement
chanceuse puis gdg des amis très proches
dans la communauté lgbt tue plus
genre tu chanceux j'ai rien choisi de
tout sa tige dengue dans un écosystème
où par la force des choses c'est que
j'ai des amis qui sont venus me raconter
leur leur for intérieur s'ouvrir à moi
en tant qu'ami saut j'ai jamais eu à
aviv comme un immense écart avec avec
toutes ces groupes-là qui lutte en ce
moment je suis chanceux t je me mets à
la place de ceux qui n'ont jamais été en
contact avec des gens différents
parce que c'est sûr que c'est toi tu le
dis quand arrive justement dans une
période où est ce qu'était cette
comprendre quitter ouais puis vous dire
ça c'est cécile que pour tout le monde
en rentrant au cégep ou dans ces
enjôleurs c'est l'adolescence puis le
début de l'âge adulte mais essaie de
comprendre quitter tout eu la chance de
trouver un milieu d'hommes et on l'a la
radio étudiante
s'il y avait des gens comme ça que tu as
réussi à kiki avait qui étaient tous un
petit peu comme ça mais j'imagine que
pour certaines personnes car tu arrives
à cette recherche la peinture réalise
que ce que tu es ça concorde pas
vraiment avec ce que tout le monde
autour de toi et ne prend vraiment que
tu as tendance à essayer de répressif
qui te rend différent exact puis de 2,6
tivité avec tout le monde
exact puis ça c'est si l'affairé ultra
prestige trouve que dans l'identité dans
mon chez moi j'aime savoir comme la vie
comme une expérience tu viens une fois
moi je suis fasciné par le fait qu'on
vient une fois intégrative et oui ok on
peut peut-être un potentiel de
réincarnation mais tu viens une fois tu
écris cran
ces débats tard il faudrait faire
attention et ne pas les bouts d'essai
rester jeune et en forme il a peut-être
je reviens fourmis mais ce que je veux
on vient une fois chez moi je fasciné
par ces d'eilat et puis quand tu viens
une fois [ __ ] une chance d'être toi
même ouais pirette toi même c'est fort
qu'il compliqué mais c'est simple mais
si un stick c'est compliqué oui mais sur
papier c'est simple je sois toi même
tout le monde le dit partout le plus
important c'est d'être toi même
relis toi c'est qui c'est quoi en tirant
pratiquer toi même c'est comme c'est un
instit combat parce que vous le
découvrir c'est pas juste de la est
celle de découvrir aussi l'exact c'est
comme une aventure découvrir tekki une
aventure c'est comme faire des friches
et à l'intérieur de toi toute la marde
que tu a accumulé puis tous les costumes
que tu a accumulé puis tous les tics
pili code que tu a accumulé pour ne
jamais être différent ou ne jamais trop
être exclue d'un groupe puis plus tu
avances dans la ville qui comprend que
rocky genre il faut que je me débarrasse
de tel costume tel masque telle affaire
tu peux a tranquillement devenir
toi-même puis ça fait du bien mais ça
vient avec des avions avec beaucoup de
cd deuil devenir soi même parce que tu
réalises que des gens autour de toi tu
les a intégrés dans ta vie par mensonge
comprend pas par nécessité de soutenir
un mensonge que tu faisais croire à toi
même tu es avec ça si ça c'est un
bouquet durs dans la vie moi je pense
hélas l'âge adulte la autour de 27 30
ans que tu commences à réaliser ces
choses là mais aussi des petites huttes
et encore tu arrives là tu veux si tu
veux juste vivre comme tout le monde
s'est tu veux sentir que à cet âge là
dessus sans que le monde est devant toi
puisque jean tout et tout est
extraordinaire tout ce qui s'en vient
fait que moi j'ai vécu beaucoup de
solitude dans mon programme au cégep à
cause de ça j'ai vraiment abandonné
nicolas g j'écoutais plus à jallais plus
en classe je comprenais rien chez
jusqu'à phoques en plus il ya des gars
qui avaient ri de moi parce que j'avais
nommé mon film préféré et puis la liste
et quant à stx est facile comme choix
avant les marches géantes indienne pôle
fixe au sgc pillay il ricane est plat ça
m'a tellement fait c'est comme c'est
tellement bon non mais toi aujourd'hui
je pense fait comme il n'y a pas de
débat là dessus mais à l'époque avec des
jeunes gars des jeunes filles de 17 ans
qui veulent montrer que je suis juste
tellement montrer qu est il plus en
avant roger couderc faut c'est que j'ai
la réponse est facile puis moi ça m'a
tellement fait mal léché 20g pas bon
comme je suis pas bon ils sont bon oeil
et son nez là dedans y voit ça débite
son petit moi je connais mon meilleur
film supporter sectionnant qu'il faut
peut-être pas fait faire du cinéma
j'ai abandonné - le cinéma les fous à
mon premier cours et ouais ouais à cause
des jets pas abandonner parce qu'après
ça j'en ai refait ben oui c'est ce que
je disais que dans ma tête c'est bon les
spas pour moi bien plus tous les lire et
les réal les real c'est toujours les
plus cool au cégep et même quand tu
vieillis
la majorité des réals et les personnes
cool délit drame ouais comme des espèces
de l'idée pour la plupart des leaders
négatifs du commun c'est du monde qui du
monde qui veulent des positions de
pouvoir à la base que c'est
questionnable comme moi je moi pour moi
tu es censé découvrir ton leadership
n'est pas sensible imposé compris ce que
je dis c'est comme tu es censé dans à
travers ta route réalisé que à fort que
je suis peut-être un réal ch'ti franck
le genre j'apprenne à faire à ta barnes
aviaire américain pour moi c'est pas
comme t'es pas senti très bien madame je
serai un réalisateur c'est que vif et
sage injuste je compose à trois mois
s'est pas de mousse moi moi dans la vie
j'ai l'impression que se découvrir ça
vient avec une part de il faut que je
développe ça maintenant il faut que je
développe cette aptitude là ok parce que
genre ça résonne en moi je dois raconter
des histoires je me sens bien quand je
raconte une histoire
ok mais aussi j'aime ce genre le gras
qu'elle plus d'amis comme quoi ça corel
avec raconter des histoires lequel plus
d'un mythe commun comme c'est à 17 ans
du 6 au 8 real pour justement vous c'est
un égout et claude lelouch là dedans
pas nécessairement parce que c'est sûr
qu'il ya des gens qui ouvraient ya des
gens qui savent jeunes qu'est ce qu'ils
veulent faire je veux pas discréditée du
tout du tout seul mais mais je trouve
qu'il ya comme il ya quand même entente
entre les exceptions et comme une espèce
de monde de normal de chercher de
découvrir exactement exactement parce
qu'on se fait souvent sur les exceptions
pour plaire c'est souvent le monde se
penche sur le 5 % way 400 et un génie la
quinzaine des gens qui avaient tout
compris combien combien de secours mis
combien artistes ont travaillé tellement
fort pour longtemps qui comme l'un qui
le hue en est simple qui était jusqu'ici
cette année s'il est l'extrait minorité
puis les histoires qu'on aime raconter
sur le cendrillon le techcenter mets
typiques travail et lampis souvent
succès même instantanée se passe quand
tu le vois pas le travail qui est en
arrière mais il y en eut en crise
exane qui ont travaillé dix ans dans
l'ombre pour avoir un succès instantané
en game exactement exactement pour moi
c'est ça que moi c'est ça que j'aime en
vieillissant c'est le travail j'aime
j'aime le monde qui connaissent la
valeur du travail j'aime les gens pour
ça que genre je préfère filer avec un
paysagiste qu'avec un artiste ok je
préférais avec un gars qui travaille en
construction un mécanicien que tu l'aies
avec un artiste parce que genre comme je
m'identifie pas nécessairement au monde
artistique
moi j'aime le monde que j'en ris lève le
matin puis ils vont travailler pour
gagner leur vie ce témoin c'est de là
que je viens j'aime pas j'aime pas le
monde sont comme j'ai une position
particulière privilégié parce que genre
tout le monde admire les gens dans
l'espace public fait que yaya stick
shooter moi ça m'écoeure tafer là comme
je tu ils encore avec les mêmes amis que
j'avais quand j'avais 8 ans puis ma
famille
ils vivent dans le même quartier où j'ai
grandi puis comme je peux pas je
préparais concilier une vie de vedette
avec cette vie là tu comprends obligé de
rester le gars que je suis je me
rappelle la première fois que je t'ai vu
ouais à un vrai c'était je pense que
c'était mont royal je me rappelle bien
qu'ils étaient fermés ok puis je
marchais avec ma soeur
longtemps je sais où tu t'en vas tu es
aussi barré l'accès une charrette jaser
avec un gars qui apparemment devait être
ton ami qui est en train de faire curie
job c'est comme les rues sont fermées
puis à plein il ya plein cuisinier est
en train de faire cuire genre de la
viande avec la coriandre hachée par les
deux multi 0 genfit le juste avec la
avec le doute qui est la difficulté
d'histoire pizza exactions mais bon ami
année signant un café ils s'appellent
les kawa café sur mont-royal puis quand
il ferme la rue c'est bon ça c'est une
histoire et j'aurais voulu que tu
m'avais vue pendant que je servais lmnp
[Rires]
non je servais puis cris et qu'à chaque
fois que je vais les bills que c'est
toujours les ventes de trottoirs jaurès
et chaque fois que je vais l'aider il
commence à crier genre venez c'est la
vedette difficulté jusqu'à faire mme
schaaphok eagle bogey comme moi ça moi
c'est ça que j'aime c'est j'aime le côté
j'ai j'ai pas choisi d'être un artiste
j'ai pas choisi toute cette vie là je
connais le pouvoir qui vient avec il ya
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de pouvoir
dans l'espace public là puis j'ai vu
trop de gens y compris une partie de moi
ou une partie de moins certain moment la
possibilité de se corrompre en soi même
le pouvoir ça qu'auront les gens
absolument ne peut pas connaître
quelqu'un avant qu'ils aient eu du
pouvoir
quand il a du pouvoir c'est là que s'ils
connaissent et là quand il ya de
l'argent ou ou comment on peut qualifier
le pouvoir c'est sous l'admiration aussi
son admiration l'agent de la c1 c'est
admiration pour jean argent sexe puis
je sais pas j'ai peur x partout tu vas
genre le monde ne sait pas s'ils étaient
des espèces de privilèges l'été ça c'est
le pouvoir
l'accord quant à salade peut connaître
quelqu'un puis moi je suis pas un fan de
dix minutes
moi j'ai pas un fan comme je le dis
ouvertement que j'ai pas
individuellement
j'aime tout comme je peux aimer tout le
monde mais le milieu la culture de ce
milieu là comme jeu là je jeu là j'ai
pas envie de dire un mot agressif je je
je me réserve d'angers mais réserve 2010
du show business québécois maintenant je
lis jamais ça l'espace public plus que
le show-biz parce que moi dès que tu es
aujourd'hui on a plusieurs façons de
devenir très connue fait que c'est plus
juste le ch ob c'est vraiment comme
l'espace québec à partir du moment que
tu as une position que tu veux dire j'ai
une tribune les gens me suivent ne me
vois pas d'accord avec la culture
convoqué ce que qu'est ce qu'ils sont
d'après ces caisses qui sont les points
avec lesquels ça la croche pour toi
est-ce que c'est l'espèce de du moins de
mon point de vue l'espèce de deux
milieux incestueux ou est-ce que
on engage les mêmes gens on célèbre les
mêmes gens qu est-ce qu est-ce qui est
qu'est ce qui est problématique sans
quelque part le fait qu'on célèbre les
mêmes gens c'est ça qui est aussi le
gros défi je trouve quand vient le temps
de critiquer un milieu mettons dans
lequel je travaille fait que c'est que
des fois tu peux critiquer puissant tir
au fond de toi quand tu vraiment tout
accorde un moment de vérité d'intégrité
te dis ouais je critique parce que aussi
ça me fait chier moi j'aurais voulu être
là j'aurais voulu avoir si fait que ça
je mettrai ça de côté parce que je pense
que dès qu'il ya comme une possibilité
de jalousie d'un piqué ou quoi que ce
soit ça vaut plus rien c'est voir et de
débattre et tout le monde aimerait ça
brille et tout le monde aimerait ça être
dans une position haute et complimenter
au t t après si on dit bravo sûr ça ne
dérange pas je dirais plus comme le fait
que par exemple dans le milieu de
l'humour je trouve que c'est aberrant
comme aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui commence
à faire de l'humour j'ai de la peine
pour lui non mais moi j'ai de la peine
pour un jeune ou une jeune qui commence
aujourd'hui qui se dit je vais faire de
l'humour parce que le milieu est comme
n'a qu'une seule vocation c'est le
rendement c'est la seule voie qui comme
tout le monde veut devenir connu puis
vendre des affaires va puis je suis pour
ce devenons connu vendons nous à faire
mais ya pas de place pour l'art ouais
y'a pas de place pour comme j'en viens
je suis fasciné par une industrie au
grand complet qui idolâtrent yvon
deschamps qui est un [ __ ] d'artistes
c'est un artiste mais genre pur et dur
tu lis son histoire à ce gala
c'est un fait qu'un artiste mur à mur là
il ya tout fait c'est comme il déchiffre
qu'aujourd'hui on pourrait même pas
imaginer tellement c'est audacieux
d'avancé le fun je vois pas ce que je
vois pas de la place pour un yvon
deschamps au québec où je vois je vois
pas comment yvon deschamps deviendrait
yvon deschamps aujourd'hui au québec
je ne vois pas ça je n'ai pas
l'impression que un gars qui monte sur
scène un gars qui monte sur scène pour
raconter l'arrivée d'un noir dans son
quartier pipi faire un numéro complet là
dessus puis créé une commotion est
public puis et qui est un débat une
discussion sur des dix ans était tout le
temps c'était c'était tellement faim
puis artistique ce qu'il faisait
je vois pas aujourd'hui comment un
artiste un humour pourrait se dire moi
je vais faire je vois comme je veux
suivre ma voix ma vocation puis je veux
c'est obligés de camper d'un bord ou de
l'autre pis c'est trop polarisé soit et
comme dans le mainstream soit est dans
la marge pita il meanstream c'est comme
les oules entre 2 you l'entre-deux déjà
juste le gao la fille qui veut juste
faire de l'art je peins experts du
milieu du mot le pire mais l'impression
cost et stylisme risque qu'ils
réussissent à drama meanstream mais
apporter des messages des causes
vraiment forte sim et ongles une colonie
t'avais netflix le shonan est le sait
qu'il est tombé le petit savait pas le
résultat mais ce que c'est du moins ce
que ça n'est pas mais c'est quelqu'un
qui ment sur cinq qui prend position ou
alerte qui fait son truc ça ne dérange
pas de déplaire aux outils méthodes et
des chapelles tu sais qu'ils étaient
juste le dernier le dernier show qui
sort si le 10 6 8 monte sur scène pour
parler de son message que j'aimerais
sens que je peux c'est au québec on ne
plus la misère à déplaire on a plus de
la misère à confronter jeu c'est en fait
ce que j'aime les exemples que tu nommes
qu'il y en a beaucoup d'autres pays en
fait je ne mets pas au centre de demont
argumentaire le fait de m'être de duff
de dire des choses horribles revendiquer
moi je mets au centre de mon
argumentaire un écosystème qui favorise
le devenir soi-même c'est comme devenir
quitter puis c'est tellement insidieux
parce que tu rentres dans des milieux
s'appuie chaussures que beaucoup de gens
le vivent dans leur milieu de travail où
la culture qui est la juste parce que tu
veux pas être trop différents puis pas
trop déplaire puis pas trop s'y plient
pas trop ça favorise à ce que tu
deviennes quelqu'un que tu es pas si
c'est ça c'est ça que je trouve qu'ils
triste mais tant que je peux parler du
milieu de l'humour à ce jeu je le
connais bien mais je laime ce milieu là
puis j'aime beaucoup beaucoup mes
collègues j'adore mes collègues jeu hier
j'ai fait un show devant
automne j'ai vu mes collègues puis je
leur ai dit je vous aime si je content
de vous voir j'ai rien contre mes
collègues
moi je quand je parle de ces choses là
c'est vraiment en termes de culture
générale du genre tu commences animaux
puis la foule vite là qu'il faut vite
que ce soit quelqu'un des punchs et le
fauteuil déry rachats nets les taxes ou
révoquer les photos deviennent connus
il faut que la madame thérèse qui font
les maquis comme ans ferme parfois king
alon petit jeu teillé où l'espèce de
justement le lait ou le chemin pour
celui ou celle que peut-être il va
jamais devenir connus mais comme il va
gagner sa vie à être lui-même vie va
être heureux c'est ça qui marche i c'est
qu'on favorise pas être heureux il
favorise réussi où j'aimerais cent fois
mieux à être un peu connue pour quelque
chose dont je suis vraiment fier est
très connu pour quelque chose que j'ai
faite parce que je savais que j'avais
connu pour ce tout ce que moi j'ai
l'impression qu'il comme il prend
plusieurs chemins pour devenir connu et
aimé ton monte entre deux chemins et le
chemin de quelqu'un qui vaut pas de quoi
de tancer qui veut ça va donner que ça
va résonner avec du monde depuis que ça
vaut il va se passer quelque chose
pourrait bien devenir connus t mais en
faisant son truc tu mettais aussi des
fois ça soit ça sent j'ai l'impression
des fois
l'espèce de hockey mon ngolle mon bus à
être connue vu comment j'y arrive - plus
de tous les moyens sont bons
plus qu'un que tous les moyens sont bons
ce luxe a dit oui les problématiques les
violations de sécurité près à tous deux
nuls au centre de ce problème là où
cette problématique là une question
d'argent c'est pas parce que l'or au
québec est souvent subventionnés par
l'état c'est pas le cas en humour non
fait qu en humour que des produits des
producteurs
t'as tout compris en humour tu es obligé
de faire de l'argent pour être capable
d'avoir appuyé les producteurs sont tout
à fait au courant de caisse qui va
s'assurer de vendre des billets ouais
qu'est-ce qui va réussir à rendre ce
profitable si votre réussir au final à
gagner ta vie maintenant
si l'humour était considéré comme de
l'or aux mêmes scènes que des
subventions sont donnés pour des films
des films qui seront pas rentables au
box office par exemple mais qui va faire
rayonner qui vont permettre à du monde
que notamment ton frère pascal de vives
en étant un artiste en étant le plus
proche possible de qui ont envie d'être
probablement que ça viendrait est d
aider la problématique j'imagine wayne
on tâte à 100% raison mais tu mets le
doigt dessus c'est comme c'est un milieu
qui est très peu subventionné ya des
subventions il ya des crédits d'impôt ya
des chiffres comme ça le met mais c'est
un milieu qui est très peu qui est très
peu subventionné donc pour survivre dans
ce milieu là il faut faire de l'argent
ok moi je suis moins cher capitaliste
moi je suis un gars qui est payé comme
une légende rayons obliques et les
communes et ça tue plus que les genres
120 millions de personnes et six dans
les facs goulag ou en chinois au
cambodge s'est pas lassé genre oh non
mais ça n'a pas été fait
c'est à quel point tu es fort kent
arrogant pour penser que la façon que
toi tu vas le faire ça va marcher
soit c'était jamais eu le pouvoir n'a
jamais été quelqu'un qui a du pouvoir
entre le pouvoir d'une fois qu'une
civilisation entre les mêmes t comme tu
dis quoi je suis plus la même personne
farc tout le monde et si dans mes poches
c'est mal canada du ménec cet examen a
mis 6 ouais ça sonne comme une bonne
idée
c'est en tout cas je veux pas réduire ça
parce qu'il ya quelque chose de charmant
dans l'idée qu'on se partage tout mais
en même temps même pas parce que j'ai
déjà moi j'ai déjà été super fans du
genre les communistes anarchistes toutes
ces choses là jusqu'à ce que je lise
beast of the value savent c'est pas bon
mais le monde y meurt on avait lu ils
sont étudiés dans l'histoire de che
guevara qui ont le talent est là qu on
la fait genre un espèce de tour de bus
où est ce qu'on a lu loup équipé 0
combler type il y avait eu fraude qui
était vraiment clé c'était une fois
qu'ils ont qui ont décidé de céder à
cuba de rendre ce que ministre des che
guevara qui travaillaient 80 heures dans
un champ par semaine
comme se défoncer pour pour la
communauté plus la phrase a presté mais
rapidement le taux d'absentéisme montée
radical rester chez nous puis jean
l'argent va rentrer pareil mais l'autre
votre travail c'est sa mère en tout cas
les je pense que je pense il ya comme il
ya comme il ya de plus en plus haut je
sais pas j'ai peut-être les mêmes et il
ya beaucoup de gens qui détestent les
captages puis je comprends à 100% je
trouve qu'on vit encore dans une ère de
capitalisme sauvage c'est à dire le
profit à tout prix milieu des champs
mais comme il ya clairement des
changements d'heure avec l'arrivée
d'internet des réseaux sociaux de plus
en plus de gens peuvent devenir
entrepreneur avoir un contact avec leur
communauté
quand en contact avec ta communauté
pétition pourquoi tu mets tels produits
dans ton truc c'est comme c'est
cancérigène orchidées george bell
retirer tu peux maintenant tu peux avoir
une espèce de deux actions d'interaction
je dis pas que c'est parfait je sais
qu'après une chose mais j'ai
l'impression qu'on se dirige
tranquillement vers un capitalisme un
peu plus civilisée puisque j'aime
pourrais je dire que moi j'aime moi sur
le capitalisme ça donne l'opportunité de
faire ton argent puisse faire ce que tu
veux que ton argent mais si tu veux
redistribue les deux hommes comme on
parle pas de moi je vais jamais venir
ici et dire aux gens que ce que je fais
que mon argent mais comme ça fait partie
de mes valeurs d'aidé du monde autour de
moi puis d'aider des gens que je connais
même pas puis je vais pas venir me
braque bao qui comprend comme j'aime
cette opportunité là que j'ai de mettre
mon argent au service de mes valeurs
puis je trouve que c'est dans les pays
communistes que j'ai visités comme le
vietnam c'est pas quelque chose qui sont
possibles ok comme j'ai vu des policiers
au vietnam
arrivé dans avec leurs camions à cinq km
heure ça m'a marqué c'est à ce moment-là
que j'ai fait oh mon dieu
toutes ces années là je pensais que le
communisme avait quelque chose de beau
mais j'ai oublié que l'être humain comme
quand il ya du pouvoir c'est quelqu'un
de faux clubs potentiellement c'est tout
le brésil arrive avec un camion qui
roule à cinq km heure puis marche à côté
du camion vraiment avec arrogance des
pires garde les épées les paysans les
scènes espèce de souk marchés publics le
pilat y ramasse ce qu'ils veulent chez
les artisans pour les vendeurs dans la
rue puis le mettre dans le camion puis
les gens ils sont tout comme
accroupis pid dans la peur il a quand
les camions partent le monde reprennent
leur vie c'est comme walt vois ça les
gars ça c'est leur vie à tous les jours
à ces gens là à tous les jours il ya
quelqu'un qui peut venir ramasser ce
qu'ils ont c'est comme you le bonheur là
dedans c'est c'est pas ces fausses pas
quelque chose que tu vivrais au québec
ne peut prospérer tu peux dire c'est
quoi
moi j'aime planter des plantes joueurs
tranquilles je vois planter des plantes
estime que je dois faire
puis tu peux gagner ta vie à planter des
plantes tout ce que tu as à faire c'est
être bon de faire des contacts et je
dire si comme c'est génial car tu penses
mais tu es si tu veux ça partout sur
terre c'est en tout cas bref tout ce que
je dis moi j'aime et capitalise pour ça
que j'ai rien contre le côté rendement
de mon industrie mais je pense que l'ici
le québec décidé à quelques pas ramené
de d'élargir un peu puis de d'offrir une
opportunité à des chemins différents
types dumont puis je me suis même pas
moi qui en bénéficieraient pas c'est moi
je fais relativement d'humour grand
public ça va bien mais à faire j'ai pas
de gipat d'ici je suis pas là dedans
mais c'est juste je regarde les plus
jeunes qui commencent puis des fois j'ai
l'impression que la seule façon de
réussir c'est de se coller encore aux
modèles des années 90 bref on n'est pas
obligés de parler de nous mais dans son
histoire ce qu'ils n'ont même pas ce que
plus plus plus largement que l'humour tu
es moi mettons je suis allé à
l'université laval en tes ratures ok
puis d'un tintin enseignement qui est
donnée qui est le même pour tout le
monde ok fecteau les mêmes professeurs
tous les mêmes devoirs de la même façon
d'écrire tous les mêmes choses qui sont
enseignées puis ça j'ai l'impression que
ça tu peux l'unicité
ça rend un peu
claude soula diversifie tellement
d'accord chacun à quelques mois sa
statue l'unicité de chacun et c'était
j'ai l'impression que tu arrives là avec
avec tes idées moi je me rappelle qu'il
ya un jeu sorti du cégep j'avais façon
d'écrire qui était ultra sporadiques qui
était vraiment dans le ventre entre le
réel et l'imaginaire était vraiment tir
ultra unique que je me rappelle des
exercices d'écriture que que j'arrive le
plus au début je fais mon propre chuté
selon comment je l'avais instinctivement
selon comment je le vivais en moins pis
le taux des notes qui sont misérables
way ou un local finalement tu prête
réellement à la technique qui est
enseigné des notes quand ça monte plus
très bon mais c'est surtout la force et
oui je sais pas si c'est le cas c'est
même chose j'ai passé le k était à
l'école nationale de l'humour qui est
qui a monde qui à mon sens à moins d'un
1 complètement extérieur puis t'es même
pas obligé de te mouiller sur ce dossier
là mais qui est à mon avis ya moins une
drôle de façon de concevoir l'humour
comme étant un homme que tu peux
enseigner
tu peux l'encadré mettant un homme que
tu peux enseigne immodelise ça
m'apparaît comme comme bizarre comme
façon de le vent ben ça j'ai
l'impression d'entrer ja je parlais
qu'un qu'avant-hier j'ai fait un podcast
avec un gand belgique que je connais pas
je t'ai caillou j'aime le podcasting au
pyla and they genre tu conseilles tu
dialyse cheron je sais pas mais je sais
pas quoi dire comme je pense pas que ça
s'enseigne si je pense pas que je pense
pas que l'humour ça s'enseigne puis je
pense pas que le stand up surtout à 105
c'est une maladie pour moi le stand up
c'est comme si une vraie maladie mentale
non sens que si t'es pas obsédé tu
arriveras jamais tu n'y as c'est trop
dur comme c'est trop souffrant cydia
trop du 2-2 d'échec
chaque jour est un échec c'était pas
obsédé maladive mentalité comme je vois
pas comment tu peux y arriver
fake je comprends même pas comme com
ça pourrait sans saigner je pourrais pas
enseigné à quelqu'un en face du monde
j'ai l'impression puis tête aussi que le
parallèle se fait avec la musique
j'ai l'impression que ça crée des
techniciens ou des gens qui sont
capables de comprendre les mécanismes
pourraient devenir peut-être etc
écrivain pour quelqu'un d'autre de
devenir musicien pour quelqu'un d'autre
mais je n'ai pas l'impression que ça
crée j'ai pas l'impression que ça aviv
la flandre artois ouais ouais ça c'est
peut-être ce qui c'est peut-être ça qui
manque de plus en plus je trouve des
trucs que tu écoutes puis tu fais comme
tu es ils vont des chances dans
l'exemple des trucs que tu vois que tu
fais acquis non là ça c'est quelque
chose dont coin là je viens de voir
quelque chose d'autre
la personne qui mettons un humour qui me
fait dire ça c'est quelque chose dans
les dernières années c'est julien
lacroix qui est arrivé seul ennui
l'humour tu fais tabarnak si c'est quoi
ça que sais je regarde le genre ddc de
quoi que j'ai pas vu très web moi j'ai
pas l'impression que je peux dire la
même chose pour beaucoup de chocs joie
puis sortons du mont mais même de show
de musique c'est de faire marquer non là
on est ailleurs complètement web
artistiquement ailleurs mais tu sais
c'est dur le métier comme le milieu
c'est dur comme ces gens maintenant je
sais pas comment dire comme c'est comme
un louis joseph est comme une sommité là
dans notre milieu pis loup josé pour moi
c'est ce qui se rapproche le plus d'un y
vont des champs dans le sens que ce qui
fait un jour c'est sûr ça va être étudié
ça va être ça va représenter le monde la
vie des québécois comme il porte en lui
la vie des québécois dans toute son
stand-up quand il analyse c'est du fork
in génie puis il est jeune encore là
pour un humoriste il n'y a pas qu'en y
est pas encore entré dans l'âge d'or
yvon deschamps est ce qu'il est
c'est-à-dire t il vont des changements
si comme autour d'eux comme 50 là qu'il
ya de gros stocks qui a commencé à
avancer je pense à avancer il faisait
beaucoup de théâtre mais cela par son
humour assez puis c'est ça il y en a je
dis pas que je dis pas qu'il n'ya pas
deux
mais quand encore une fois je quitte les
exceptions pour dire le bassin l'été
comme il ya beaucoup le bassin mais je
pensais la même chose dans tous les
milieux
c'est comme comment on fait pour que
dans le bassin pour les personnes qui
vont pas devenir genre d exception pour
qu'il soit heureux
mais j'ai l'impression qu'on a
complémentaires cessa de la conversation
au travail c'est comme on voit tellement
de gens qui réussissent depuis là
aujourd'hui c'est rendu le rêve de tout
le monde de devenir connus comme tout le
monde va être connu
je leur avais facile d'accès aux sites
où trouve-t-on dans ta poche on a tous
dans notre poche un miroir vers la
célébrité de voir le monde fait que
j'arrive en retard dans cette affaire
l'homme de comprendre que genre comme
j'ai découvert youtube pendant la
pandémie moi j'ai de tout pour moi du
tout pour moi c'était comme l'endroit où
j'ai étudié des clips de temps en temps
ou des vidéos c'est comme j'ai découvert
que youtube sert réseau social par
l'egypte comme les gens ils vivent de ça
il y en a fort le wind et didier genre
que la brasserie que la présence de
givre ont été fascinés jeu-là mieux
chanteur pas par eux mêmes pas par
négligence
je savais pas comme chez moi pour moi
youtube c'est ce que j'avais découvert
au cégep c'est le truc qu'on allait voir
du développeur ou des sketches aux
jardins musicaux j'ai dans ma tête ça a
toujours été ça mais tout une sous
culture de mon des ultras film c'est un
certain public chez les jeunes devrait
piquer jamais ma mère ou ta mère jamais
entendu parler de ces personnes ne sont
pas des médias traditionnels brioude
exactement il ya une affaire aussi de
tout sous culture le ils font ce qu'ils
veulent ouais c'est vrai ils font ce
qu'ils veulent personne qui peut leur
dire quoi faire ouais puisse à ses hôtes
quand même c'est très hot
c'est très très hâte jusqu'à ce qu' il y
en a un ou une boutique homme qui veut
commencer à faire de l'argent mais comme
du vrai pas du vrai argent je sais qu'en
et qui font du vrai argent mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que si tu veux faire
du vrai argent est obligé de commencer à
regarder les modèles ouais tu comprends
puis ça revient toujours au même
problème c'est que quand je réussir puis
tu vas à tout prix réussir
on est toujours à imiter seul ou à
emprunter décote de ceux qui réussissent
vite dans ce chemin là tu oublies tout
le temps que le plus important c'est que
tu sois heureux quand ils couchent le
soir une telle impression que tu es en
synchronicité avec tes valeurs puis ça
il ya personne qui nous lançait jamais
été ce que tu viens de dire le ix35
route et ses valeurs pour être heureux
je pense que ça résume le truc le temps
doit vraiment et puis justement si tu
penses que la célébrité c'est la chose
qui va te faire aller mieux
non tu restes de sombrer dans une
profonde et précise des bobos la bourse
était pas bien c'est quoi que ce soit
c'est pas le fait d'être connu et même
riche qui voit la lyre aigrinois est
encore là même des fois ils vont être
payé ses factures pour faire l'avocat du
diable
avec tout cet argumentaire là je suis
d'accord avec ce que vous dites le thé
d'être en synchronicité avec ses valeurs
parce que c'est vraiment un excellent
terme
c'est sûr que c'est ce qui est optimale
mais j'ai l'impression que c'est facile
à dire mais pas facile à faire mais
vraiment difficile à faire car mettons
moi je m'imagine je veux en être
je veux être heureux qui suit par une
chaîne youtube où est ce que je fais 100
% ce qui me tend
combien de temps je peux le faire sans
faire une scène combien de temps je peux
le frère sonne comme un temps je peux
continuer le même faux faut gagner notre
vie
non il n'ya personne qui va venir
l'entraînement est tu peux le faire
parce que vous me verrez une pcu à
chaque mois - voilà comment commence au
sujet des sites est obligé de faire fait
autre chose trouve que tout ce que tu
aimes
non mais tu sais ce que je veux faire
c'est ce que j'ai fait ou un bel air on
rentre dans la sphère de lorsque terme
faire que tu serais capable de le
monétiser gagner ta vie ex cfec fait que
là on est c'est quoi ces armes et ont
placé des tubes rock ton plan b si on
dit souvent citons un plan b si tu n'as
pas de plein exercice
mais c'est pas là j'ai commencé à faire
de l'humour mon plein as tes potes
devenir connu je vous le jure est mon
âme et je ne parle même pas de devenir
connus de voir juste de réussir à gagner
ta vie de ta passion mois
plan a c'est de gagner ma vie avec la
passion mais mais mais je comprends ce
que tu dis là je me suis même d'accord
avec toi mais c'est l'impression que
j'ai l'impression que c'est clairement
on vient milieu tout à fait différent
mais j'ai l'impression que en ce moment
ci c'est le genre de choses c'est
extrêmement privilégié de pouvoir dire
c'est tout au plus un privilège comme
comme le mien de naître dans une famille
nantie demeures et cetera mais c'est
quand meme psg avoir un talent
extraordinaire
je pense que personne vole nier ça je
pense que ça m'a pris ça me prend je
suis encore en train de ne pas
comprendre que j'ai des affaires qui
sont faciles pour moi qui sont plutôt
ses soeurs et moi j'ai de la difficulté
de garantie 1 an ok on le sait on le
voit le tiens on entend parler on sict
ce talent là je n'ai pas rêvé city taxi
be puis tu parles c'est juste drôle que
j'ai envie de rire mais c'est vraiment
pas tout le monde qui ont eu le
privilège d'avoir un talent ce g10 est
dans quelque chose puis d'avoir la
réelle capacité de vivre de sa passion
puis je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de monde
qui doivent arriver à un moment où
est-ce que ils doivent combiner un petit
peu un petit peu combiné ou peut-être
pour quelque chose qui les fait pas trop
chier ouais tu leur permet de gagner
leur vie parce qu'on vit dans cette
société là fait que je pense que de dire
si et de dire ses 56 terre en 100 ans de
sa passion puisqu'ils sont gagner sa vie
j'ai l'impression que ça vient d'un
endroit privilégié de pouvoir dire et ce
à raison je te donne raison j'ai un gros
problème avec ça je la difficulté des
fois je me rappelais yacht est dans une
situation comme où il ya des choses qui
sont faciles pour toi que que ça te
permet d'avoir une vision du monde
donnait son opinion blabla quand je te
disais je m'inclus aussi de pouvoir dire
ça c'est comme le c'est un peu ce que je
fais dans ma vie mais je suis conscient
que je privilégié de pouvoir faire
sauter ouais mais ça revient ce que
j'aime
en tout cas il ya un point en commun
avec ce qu'on dit c'est que ça revient à
il faut trouver une manière de laisser
ta véritable identité naître où existait
à un moment ou un autre la timone
parce que tout va être compliqué même
même si tu as tout le talent du monde du
même statut les privilèges du monde il
n'y en a pas un ou une pour qui faire ce
que tu as à faire puis faire qu'est-ce
qui résonne en toi comme c'est pas
facile pour personne si je pense aussi
que le genre de choses qu'on dit en ce
moment vienne vient d'un de trois
personnes qui ont des aspirations
atlantique
j'ai pas l'impression que le bonheur
c'est ce pour tout le monde c'est pour
pas oublier non plus que souvent ils
demandent que leur passion c'est d'avoir
une maison une famille que c'est leur
passion j'adore ça qu'est ce qui leur
permet de vivre de leur passion c'est de
travailler par exemple ça j'ai encore
dans une place qui connaît sûrement une
passion mais qui amène vers la passion
des transactions après onze ans passés à
fléaux de société en même temps ce que
tu viens parce que ce que tu es nommé ce
soit la plus belle option que tu as ou
vraiment un fléau où tu as l'impression
que tout le monde à heath qui fait c'est
comme il ya tellement de plus en plus de
gens qui il te parlent de ce qu'ils font
ici il déteste ça puis ça me ramène à
étudier une fois sur terre comme comme
tu vas vraiment justement cet avis à je
sais pas on fait pas uniquement que
travailler tes pieds les gens qui sont
pris enfin je pense que ça qui fait sans
guillemets de faire quelque chose qui
tienne correct mais ce qu'ils aiment
vraiment si
ce qu'ils font le soir leur hobby ou
justement leur famille et puis la
réalisation personnelle vient pas d'un
travail
seppi pia est ancien chronicité avec ses
valeurs ça peut être fun c'est
maintenant justement si toi c'est
important pour toi c'est la famille
partait du temps avec des proches pythie
et d'investir là dedans fait ceci ouais
c'est ce peu importe c'est n'importe
quoi c'est de trouver ce pas
nécessairement de travail c'est juste
dans ce que tu viens 18e et en mettant
quelqu'un qui traite vraiment sur le
triathlon il veut faire du triathlon
absolument épique ça c'est sa passion
numéro un c'est le triathlon gle les
chances qu'ils soient un triathlète
professionnels sont extrêmement faibles
c'est comment je fais pour faire du
triathlon le plus souvent possible
d'acheter un job qui me permet d'arrêter
à 5h heure puis dans les farces
triathlon ouais le tue vit le jour dit à
parler du triathlon mon premier
producteur animaux étaient absents
d'hier le triathlon il ne faisait qu'une
longue et 24 ans comme je sors mon
premier show et j'ai peur pourquoi tu me
parles de triathlon com qu'est-ce qui se
passe il était vraiment obsédé c'est sûr
je pense que là ilan grapel mental un
avis que cela se savait style mais je
comprends ce que tu veux dire je
comprends métier comme aussi quand je
parle maintenant comme là on y danse et
tantôt je me sentais plus dans une
conversation la jcct ont pris conscience
qu'il y ait des gens qui coûte le tir
des gentils peut-être qu'on est dans un
bout de la conversation et des gens qui
la majorité des gens se cherchent
tout à fait oui même moi comme j'ai
l'air de savoir de quoi je parle il ya
un point pan de ma vie où je me cherche
encore beaucoup
puis je pense à ces gens là qui sont
comme qui font des affaires qui aime pas
mais c'est dur de faire ces décisions là
c'est dur de faire est en fait tout
vient avec un sacrifice t'as pas le
choix la notion de sacrifice est
fondamentale à a
à n'importe quelle aventure n'importe
quelle quête si tu veux avoir telle
affaire doit sacrifier telle ou telle ou
telle chose exactement choix mais moi
j'aime l'idée du sacrifice j'aime l'idée
que genre je vais je vais avoir un
certain des plaisirs aujourd'hui pour
avoir comme un avenir qui ressemble à un
idéal que je m'étais fixé j'aime bien ce
côté là de puis je pense que ça aussi
c'est un truc mettons à l'école on nous
apprend pas si on nous apprend pas que
dans la vraie vie c'est de même ça
marche c'est comme revenons au fait que
tout le monde va être connus aujourd'hui
moi j'ai été faire j'ai fait un court
métrage comme 3,4 en pis il fallait que
je trouve un acteur arabe bien acteur
noir
enfant il y en a pas au québec dans les
agences ont évidemment j'ai passé des
agences mais après ça j'ai été dans
l'est dans les quartiers dans mon
quartier d'enfance je fais passer des
auditions jiji
j'ai passé une audition 150 noirs et
arabes de dix ans qu'un pays comme tous
me disais que des étoiles dans les yeux
que parce que je leur faisais tout à peu
près la même audition des étoiles dans
les yeux que leur rêve était de devenir
connus pas acteur ou chanteur ou connu
ça c'est comme le rêve sauf si c'est pas
si j'ai j'en revenais pas à quel point
jean c'est connu c'est pas une métier
iard est devenu un sens oui oui mais oui
mais comme si même si tu veux devenir il
faut que tu apportes quelque chose à la
donne
oui il faut que tu apportes quelque
chose même si tu fais rien vite neyton
rien doit être quelque chose - en fait
les gens ils sont comme ils se
reconnaissent
pis si tu veux que ce soit j'ai juste
steyn bobo la tête mais si tu veux que
ça le père du roi et où durable genre il
faut que tu sois capable d'avoir une
certaine discipline fonctionnaires de
sacrifier des affaires dans ta vie c'est
comme ça vient avec tout un modèle de
travail qui traite obligé d'apprendre
comme je dis y'a pas sur ce facteur
pourquoi puis qu'est ce que tu vas faire
avec justement par les pouvoirs tantôt
qu'est ce que nous avons fait avec ce
pouvoir lequel vous êtes reconnu tipi
qui dira si on connaît vraiment
quelqu'un quand quelqu'un qui a du
pouvoir - justement
c'est site ici les influenceurs ce qu'on
dit aux jo c'est super car l'influencé
bonne si mauvais cas l'influencé
mauvaise jeu des pires pays au lieu de
tous les deux tant qu'à moitié mais
justement si tu vas être connus trouve
toi une raison pour laquelle tu fais ce
point c'est moi ça me fait capoter qui
était tellement du monde avec tellement
de pouvoir pitié on parlait des
capitalistes rudiments du jeff bezos
demain matin il peut arrêter là
finalement de 7 ans mais je pense
vraiment qu'ils pourraient faire sa ba
il pourrait le faire vraiment pour un
bout pour 10 - un grand nombre de
personnes
moi je pense que si jeff bezos ce donne
un million de dollars à une famille qui
a pas d'argent la famille ça va la
détruire possiblement ils vont tout plus
parler ils vont se battre pour l'argent
comme moi je viens d'une famille pauvre
comme je dis pas que ma famille aurait
fait ça mais comme je ne sais quel idéal
de comme sortir les gens de la pauvreté
qu'on se fixe dans la tête c'est une
affaire qui me fascine avec les gens est
encore arrivée dans le milieu je pensais
que les gens
moi je me vois comme une personne plus à
gauche je me vois comme une personne à
gauche
je pensais que les personnes à gauchy y
comprenez que genre moi je viens de la
pauvreté mais comme toutes les personnes
d'où je viens et veulent devenir riche
s'ils veulent pas devenir comme ils
veulent
ils veulent ce qu'ils voient le tournoi
comme choquante et à gauche mais tu te
bats pour les pauvres tout bois pour du
monde leur leur rêve c'est de faire de
l'argent un jour peut-être dans une
poule c comme fish
moi je dis pas ça pour dire je pense
vraiment que donner trop de quelque
chose à quelqu'un qui n'est pas prêt à
le recevoir
c'est comme faire bencher quelqu'un
genre 200 livres quand il peut juste
bencher 56 c'est pour ça que genre oui
je pense que des riches pourraient
sauver le monde donc je pense qu'il ya
comme une manière de donner qui est
raisonnable pour pas déstabiliser
complètement un écosystème geste
déstabiliser fait juste des fois je mets
ça revient ou pourquoi les gens veulent
être connue parce que les gens veulent
les labels voiture ils veulent luc s'ils
veulent leur resto ils veulent ils
veulent sentir que les gens y ont des
prétendants des prétendantes
c'est comme le rêve on vont bien là
dedans je veux pas vain depuis qu'on est
tout petit ce qui valorise et c'est ça
qui est valorisé de baisser ce qui c'est
ça qui est encore et je pense qu'il sera
toujours je dois te regarde à travers
une sorte d'humanité a toujours eu du
monde qui trichent risques et ses caves
le poirier puis j'aurais bien cotés
comme mais je sais pas si on devrait
juger ça mais au juste
et ça rende compte pc de dire au monde
comme mais de toute façon on ne peut pas
dire au monde ça sert à rien de rêver à
ça parce que je peux pas empêcher
quelqu'un de rêver non plus petit qu'un
quidam qui dans son projet de pauvreté
de dire aux mères salariées le titre se
pose pas plus d'argent compte rendu
heureux je pense que quand même un seuil
à mal j'ai du pain blanc
pourtant j'y vois pas de la journée pas
tant que ça m'aiderait un tout petit peu
je pense qu'il ya un seuil à manier je
commente iquique comme une base
d'amandes et peut-être qui est entré ces
entrefaits 200000 ou huit cent mille si
je pensais du cent mille peut-être bien
très bien
[Musique]
j'étais totalement d'accord le mettais
je dire c'est comme il vient un point où
tu réalises que ce qui t'es comme les
gens ce qu'il y fait avancer c'est c'est
leur objectif pour cette année où la
limite très justement comme on dit moi
je suis fasciné par on est tous
tellement différent t on à tellement
différent comme on a des choses en
commun mais on est tellement fait aucune
différence juste matin gecko buts et en
auto puis avec quelqu'un il est habillé
d'une manière que je dis pas que je
trouvais ça l'est chez jusqu'à je
m'habillerais jamais
jamais pensé jamais j'aurais choses
mystiques ce vêtement là à sortir de
chez nous mais comme peut-être lui face
à une chose que moi mais on est
tellement différent on est le même
miroir à la maison moi j'aurais fais
jamais shore de même puis tout à fait
tranquille je vais mourir comme ça
ces habits neufs que j'ai un moment de
réalisation le bfr est ch'ti qu'on est
pareils on est tellement tu faire un fou
un mois mais on dirait qu'on n'oublie
cette affaire moi c'est moi en fait
toute ma vie je dis oublier en fait la
majorité de ma vie j'ai vécu en pensant
que tout le monde était à peu près
pareil non m'envoyer tout le monde à peu
près pareil c'est pour ça que quand
quelqu'un dit quelque chose que je ne
comprenais pas je sais qu'en prévoyant
puisqu'ils ce qui l'est c'est qu'est-ce
qui a mangé ce matin lui jusqu'à
envisager réalise non non non au mieux
vraiment du monde on et dont les
différents la première y est on respire
on va aux toilettes on mange puis comme
on aime notre famille c'est ce qu'ont en
commun et tout le reste rien à voir des
moines et juin
j j'étais un peu gelé ok j'ai eu cette
réflexion le mais je me disais c'est à
mettons-la êtres humains
chaque être humain vois les couleurs
différentes ok on pourrait jamais savoir
ben ouais c'est parce que depuis qu'on
est tout petit c'est quand la
professeure montre un carton bleu bien
dit ça c'est bleu bleu
peut-être que pour vous autres bleus
cessé jusqu'à ce que quelqu'un fasse un
accident de voiture puis que là-haut lui
disent qu'est ce que c'est basique
bestaven maintenant je n'étais pas avec
la même chose ok ce matin que peut-être
que ton va dans un glitch les leds
blanches dessert déjà je me suis dit
qu'un moyen qu'on pourrait le savoir
pitié tout ce qui est qu'est ce qui est
beau qu'est ce qui laisse les
constructions sociales - tfz mettons un
mois ce combo de couleurs les beaux mais
s'est construit socialement affecte pas
comme beaucoup d'autres convoquent leur
complément différent mais il est beau
aussi il ya une portion je pense de
construit social mais il ya aussi une
potion de l'être humain est obsédé par
la beauté
que sais tu le vois tu es comme juste
non mais parce que la beauté est
tellement selon les époques selon le
temps oui mais oui subjectif jusqu'à un
certain point
jusqu'à un certain point comme il ya
déjà c'est comme il ya des gens ils sont
définitivement plus beau que d'autres
comme moi je disais que je pense que
c'est selon nos standards en ce moment
je pense que ultime manche ultime ans on
peut on peut trouver quelqu'un de mille
fois plus magnifique quelqu'un puis une
autre personne que tout le monde va dire
ah c'est la belle personne ça je pense
que 100% mais d'un point de vue mettant
objective je trouve que j'habite en ce
moment que je travaille sur scène ou
jeudi je suis moi j'étais fort qu'il
l'est quand j'étais petit il était
aujourd'hui je trouve que je me donne
encore une espèce de sept sur dix la je
trouve ça pas à choquer ma face mais
comme quand j'étais petit une instit
phase de morveux et couvé dans crash
mais je ne veux des fois je me faisais
battre jusqu'à des farc et les plages
non visible chez comme j'habite ou jeudi
au monde a été dire aux enfants
on est tous beaux égal comme non il ya
déjà il faut qu'il fallait face du
karaté comme moi mon père m'a inscrit au
karaté pour que je pense que je rêvais
de jouer le rôle de yoya légal qui m'a
tapé à l'école et comme ok bio faut
compter ce crime au karaté élèves que
t'as plus rien pas pourtant exactement
tv c'est juste de ce point de vue là je
pense qu'il ya comme ya vraiment rien
le monde est injuste le monde est
fondamentalement injuste dans ce sens
que comme j'ai pas un gros qui tranche
éric microscopique comme j'aurais adoré
avant nestea ces genres juste un beau
cul mais j'ai pas ça comme je peux faire
tous les squats que je veux encore un et
steed qu de marathoniens et l'été genre
juste aider j'aime j'aime mon cul je dis
pas qu'il est pas beau mais je fais
juste dire comme des fois tu regardes
ton corps tu regardes tu as fast
regarder à petit tu te regardes ton
talent ta beauté tu dis ok genre j'imite
dealé avec ce que j'ai parce que il ya
des gens ils sont plus beaux que moi
puis moi j'accepte cette réalité-là
ressasser 11 ans pour ça c'est au sein
d'une société qui eux
ça reste en dehors de tyne wear est ton
cul comment parler de mon âge a
maintenant métallique une zone et l'asie
ont écrit les boutons étant donné qu il
met donc ok mon quartier au secondaire
le petit cul ok ok les petits culs le
genre est la fille d'un beau petit culte
et pile tu vois aujourd'hui c'est comme
l'obsession inverse si l'obsession
maximum et mes goûts par rapport à se
changer oui probablement parce que dans
l'imagerie qui nous y est véhiculé ans
que nicki minaj est arrivé puis quelques
à la chaîne d'arriver au caire piqué
l'ailé in-stat belle bleue était
compagnie ou est-ce que c'était plus de
tout d'un coup c'est plus d'aidé mais
courbet corot bleutée qui le christ le
migou on y arrive et lui effectué mais
c'est vraiment une affaire de deux
sociétés puis des dates du temple qu'est
ce qui valorise et puis qu'est-ce qui
est considéré comme hbo a assurément ce
à quoi on est exposé va jouer sur qu'est
ce qu'on va trouver
mais après ça je pense qu'il ya quand
même un beau universel un bout universel
bassiste et mettons donc même en ce
moment on rentre dedans mais je n'ai
jamais fait mais qu'apparemment rentrer
dedans puis que le même sentiment de de
beauté beauté complète est le même que
ceux qui rentraient quand ça a été ok
pour moi à moins que quelqu'un pourrait
trouver les ce que ça représente 6 mai
mais promettant un exemple un coucher de
soleil un esprit de soleil lorsqu'il ya
plein de couleurs ça se mélange les
raisons que le sel est en furie pis que
j'aie jamais rencontré quelqu'un qui
essaye donne envie de vomir
je comprends que l'on prend à coucher de
soleil était un événement naturel comme
ceux aussi ou une aurore boréale mettons
qu'il va faire et vous aura boréale ça
ça me donne de l'urticaire
audrey certaines choses comme ce métier
et la beauté et dans l'objet est pas
juste dans le par ce que je me trompe
mais tant qu'on prend à part lancé
d'exemple à une rose métier nocebo et
personnes qui ont une rose qui estime
dans l'amitié de voir surtout mais aussi
depuis qu'on ne puis que l'être humain a
commencé à mettre sur papier quelques
chose ça a été belle comme une rose
les couchers de soleil combien de fois
même décrit soleil s'est représenté
comme étant le summum du beau dans la
loire dans ce que tu vois dans la
littérature ou dans les films c'est la
même chose avec des aurores boréales des
aurores boréales toujours à chaque fois
que cela était représenté c'est un
cliché qui s'accumulent quatre villes
t54 présenter témoin de tout
est-ce que pour moi c'est beau parce que
c'était fait convaincre que c'était beau
mais peut-être parce que cet effet
convaincre la rareté de la pureté de la
beauté de tuer si je mens s'il ya
quelque chose qui résonne fort en nous
quand on est témoin de la beauté si je
pense qu'il ya des beauté universelle
effectivement je croyais vraiment aussi
comme au temps des objets que des décors
que des
des paysages des gens des individus du
bateau comme tout va tomber sur quelque
chose quelqu'un comme wahou puis une
grande majorité des gens bien comme moi
aussi je pensais ça fait partie de ce
qui motive l'être humain la beauté si on
veut des belles affaires autour de nous
on veut des on veut on compte quand on
tombe amoureux on veut trouver la
personne bell où on veut attirer par sa
beauté dit c'est comme ça revient savez
c'est vraiment un grand motivateur chez
l'être humain
ouais et et je pose des questions mais
parce que je réfléchisse à voix haute le
mais possiblement que ce que c'est vrai
que c'est pourquoi est-ce que tu arrives
dans un endroit comme mettons un champ
bucolique qu'elle est et apaisée je vais
piloter juste bien passé vraiment que ça
va bien avec absolument absolument plus
sûr que via des niveaux de notes et de
notre champ de perception qui réagit
avec la beauté d'une manière très tu
peux pas mettre le doigt dessus utc
comme très métaphysique lomé mais ça
semble être très très présentera
l'histoire d'humanité comme la recherche
du beau puis faire quelque chose de beau
pis dialogues de platon qui sont
incroyables sur le sur la boa sur la
beauté hockey vraiment vraiment c'est
justement en pis on n'arrive jamais à
déceler sais quoi mais par le dialogue
est ce que c'est ce nom sait pas ce qui
s'est passé c'est que ça réduit la zone
jusqu'à ce qu'on aille presque le doigt
dessus
finalement on ne jamais mais c'est
vraiment c pip y mettons chez platon
plage sonne comme un expert un fils
n'ont pas du tout le genre j'ai fait mes
flou c'est à tout le monde c'est c'est
une des sources de la philosophie le ccc
la beauté une vraie c'est l'étonnement
et la beauté à la source de toute
réflexion parce que la vie autant ses
souffrances ses phoques top c'est beau
comme quand son entente arrêté vais
regarder les choses telles qu'elles sont
c'est la beauté prend plusieurs formes
bi si on est
c'est comme si on avait réservé ce genre
de conversation là à la poésie où
justement à la philosophie mais comme
juste quelqu'un qui s'arrête la pie qui
regarde autour de lui tout le monde
c'est ça qu'il faut que tu as plus et
bowl il ya beaucoup de leaders mais
c'est beau c'est une des choses qui nous
rejoint tous - c mettons quelqu'un qui
parle justement philosophe qui a fait
des post doctorants philo ou quelqu'un
qui a un job est normal qu'ils
s'expriment pas plus qu'il faut vaincre
vos ennemis
face à quelque chose de beau les devants
là le maire la même sensation seront pas
capable de l'exprimer de la même façon
ouais ils vont ressentir la même chose
ils trouveront pas toutes les mêmes
choses bêtes par exemple si on prend
l'exemple du coucher de soleil les deux
vendeurs à coucher de soleil se profile
mais la beauté en or par exemple est
tellement subjectif c'est juste fêter ce
qui fait l'histoire de laure londres et
que c'est l'histoire du plus
représentative thème justement la
chapelle sixtine le cessé de peindre
c'est vraiment les choses métier d'une
manière très réaliste lundi même si
c'est des anges et compagnie
puis ce serait comme le sens même du
bottier un peu plus l'histoire avance
plus tu vois qui est belle les fonds
sont déformés le si on met ce c'est beau
parce que tu es chez artistes vivants
dit ceci plus proche d'eux du vrai de
l'intérieur des témoins les
représentations peau du monde extérieur
commun que j'observe mes de mon monde
intérieur
ces choses là il faut croire à ces
choses pipi plus avant justement
l'histoire dispose du plus figuratifs ou
plus abstraite incertain 1 certaines
pièces ou sans musique
que ce soit en arts visuels en que ce
soit si tu arrive à un point où est ce
que si carré blanc sur fond blanc le tpn
qui étaient quittés une toile blanche
moi c'est ma mère qui m'a fait réaliser
que que
on avait un monde intérieur qui était à
la recherche de de comprendre la beauté
et comprendre la sensation de la beauté
à travers une oeuvre abstraite et comme
ma mère space est pas une femme qui voit
dans les musées de ce que je suis allée
jamais été aux musiques nous on a jamais
ce pas nécessairement quelqu'un qui voit
jamais acheté une toile à la maison t'es
bien m'amener à est tombé sur une toile
d'une oeuvre abstraite et est resté
devant pie l essayer de la comprendre
puis d'exprimer commençant tel jeu c'est
comme ça le touche et pl à l'intérieur à
voyait des affaires puis à voulait comme
l'exprimé je sers mieux 1er sprint
personnes y vivent au musée pitch est
qu'elle fait face à une toile puis
naturellement instinctivement la beauté
que ça représente pour elle ça évoque
quelque chose en elle c'est ça aussi je
pense c'est ça aussi qui rend la beauté
fauque top c'est que ça oui il ya des
formes de beauté universelle
il ya aussi des formes de beauté qui
évoque quelque chose à l'intérieur de
toi et ça ça te connectes à la l'objet
ou à la personne d'une manière assez
puissante l'été ces fours est assez
haute et châteaux musées icom
et comme un nom je sais pas jusqu'à quel
musée j'adore chaque fois que je vais
dans une ville jacques un musée puis je
vais au musée puis genre chalet dans un
musée je m'en rappelle plus et qui
lartige les notés mais c'était juste
plein de panneaux des couleurs
différentes mais des instits groupe à
nola des espèces de j'ai envie de dire
genre 20 pieds de hockey ça c'est une
énorme parade énorme atout c'est
vraiment vrai c'était vraiment c'est
vrai puisque beaucoup ben moi quand même
assez vrai comme ça c'est vrai comme le
plafond ok parfait mais c'est à peu près
ça c'est moins de 20 épisodes toujours
dit ça c'est dit ok bon alors je dirais
comme qu'inspire ok 15 pieds de haut
puis chaque panneau avec une couleur
différente
puis je te jure je sais pas qu'est ce
qui s'est passé je j'avais l'impression
d'être haye
j'ai rien je regardais que je passais
d'une couleur à l'autre je comprenais
pas je suis resté là jean 30 minutes pin
à ce jour à chaque fois que je repense à
toutes ces couleurs losc je sais pas
qu'est ce qu'il a fait
inquiet c'est sûr que lui l'artiste qui
a fait seul chaque étape de cette oeuvre
abstraite il ya du tellement attendre
qu'ils sentent que c'est la perfection
pour lui qu'ils sentent que c'est
exactement ce qu'il fallait je crois pas
que j'étais arrivé bien morose sur un
panneau je pense qu'il ya travaillé son
rose qu'est ce que la couleur pour lui
ça fasse résonner quelque chose en lui
ça adonne stx a résonné chez moi moi je
suis resté regarder ces panneaux le gt
genre de gars à l'enquêté comme ménages
obligés abstrait je la regarde plus que
l'art pictural parce que j'ai parce que
ça parle à tout un monde intérieur qu'on
a avec lesquels on n'est pas trop au
contact et dans le monde dans la vie de
tous les jours deux choses premièrement
c'est clairement plus que dix pieds au
cul
deuxièmement en train de lire la femme
qui fuit à nice dont l'aval est non
seulement un excellent roman type il
raconte l'histoire de deux singles et sa
grand mère maternelle qui était parti du
mouvement automatiste des années 40-50
le titre d'artiste qui si elle était
marcel barbeau qui est à peindre son
mari puis parce que puis c'était
vraiment la pulsion le steak comme on se
pose pas de questions je te manque
utiliser le rose le sicom on met en
garde toute sa toile par instinct piste
aussi la chose qu'il a plus vraiment
parce que c'est safety venus d'inde une
pulsion intérieur automatique c puis un
passage dans les faits on trouvait ça
forge tu as menti elle son mari pour
travailler payer une toile qui vierge
qui quittera nc piloter l autre en
fonction justement son faux dans ce très
denses courants le dota mathieu a dit
chris us le goût de peindre un oiseau un
bel oiseau classe mais à peine 3 ou bien
contente et fière qu'elle trouve beauté
puis le lot tirant depuis fin juin
tellement qu'au des gens tellement j'ai
vécu quelque chose
ah ouais ouais je jure évidemment hyper
part déçu parce qu'ils trouvent que
l'oiseau de ces belles trouées déjà vu
déjà fêté
t mais ça doit trouver ce que tu roubaud
beauté ouais t'as le droit puis mais tu
vois qu est-ce qui est le gars lui a dit
la caisse des trucs s était vécu comme
ça moi j'ai vécu une affaire j'en riais
comme pas ce qui m'a pris cinq ans genre
j'ai commencé à peindre
puis je peignais des toiles abstraites
j'ai pas ce que j'avais je sais comme
dès que je me mettais à peine je parte
elle il marchait tellement loin comme un
truc qu aucune autre forme d'art m'a
fait vivre ailleurs moi ce que mon vrai
vrai à est mon vrai fixe artistes et que
c'est écrire parce que georges part dans
des flots pigeons j'oublie que j'existe
pendant une heure ou deux puis je
reviens sur terre battue mais pence et
encore plus deep que ça pis j'en ai j'ai
peint une toile plus jeune ami qui est
venu chez nous non ce n'est pas ce qui
s'est passé j'ai peint une toile puis a
trouvé tellement laide
j'ai tellement dégueulasse je les jeter
ok aux poubelles avec mes poubelles puis
cinq secondes après que je sois monté
chez nous il ya plein de monde des
jeunes jeudi des jeunes changent avec 27
pays d isabella d'argent 18-19 son corps
ils sont arrivés sur marie j'habitais
sur des bus dion n'est pas qui criait
work route soit comme pourquoi est ce
que quelqu'un jette rsa c'est tellement
beau jeu car c'est la chose la plus
laide que j'ai vu de ma vie mais ça me
fait du bien de le faire mais je
trouvais ça i de l'été puis trouvé ça
beau dans tout cas fait que ça m'a
vraiment encouragée j'ai fait cette fois
je vais en refaire une autre
j'en ai fait une autre j'en ai fait une
autre paire man et j'ai un ami qui est
rentré chez moi le gars dont on parlait
tout à l'heure le que tu me devais faire
des stars pidjot depuis venus qui a vu
mes toiles puis a fait que je veux que
tu exposes à mon café
il m'a dit je te donne jusqu'au mois
d'août il va exposer je veux dix toiles
moi je trouvais que je parle un peintre
mais je trouvais que le défi c'était
l'fun un tipi je me suis vraiment
investi puis j'ai peint pendant comme
deux mois gilles pagé pain dix toiles
puis j'ai pris ça très au sérieux j'ai
accroché puis genre comme j'en ai vendu
janek j'en ai donné y en a qui vrillent
j'ai des amis qu il
vraiment que je voudrais sa toile
jusqu'à mieux c'est de la poubelle jaune
comme je t'aime maman je t'aime pareil
ville aussi muet puis j'étais vraiment
content d'avoir fait ça pis y'a un
peintre calé à ce qu'a fait la birmanie
est venu me voir il m'a regardé qu'un
seul qui était qu un effet un
commentaire c'est dégueulasse que ce
fait et geste fait 1800 un peintre genre
dans une autre vie c'est comme un
peintre professionnel pilote il fait
plus haut visiblement là ils travaillent
dans des dans une papeterie pillay est
mis avec tellement d'amertume et mathis
dégueulasse qui se fait mais comme c'est
un monsieur de 70 ans qui mute un gars
de 27 ans c'est dégueulasse que ce fait
pile à moi ça m'a tellement fait mal
léché comme j'ai passé assez dégueulasse
je lui avais dit genre quelque chose
comme juvénile je pense y avait dit non
juive il fait genre ouch puis ça c'est
ça fait partie de ça fait partie du
parcours du chemin de fer dire qu'ils
étaient nuls à chier par quelqu'un que
toi tu peux même regardé avec des yeux
un peu admiratif
parce que tu sais que c'est un
professionnel ou mais comme à ce jour je
me dit encore ce genre d'êtres humains t
comme moi je veux jamais être ça pour
quelqu'un ne veut jamais être sur le
chemin de quelqu'un la personne qui qui
lui a fait douter de la valeur de son
bonheur à faire quelque chose c'est
comme tu as le droit de te le droit de
faire quelque chose puis pas être un
expert tu as le droit de faire quelque
chose puis pas être un professionnel
c'est pour ce qui est des fois y'a jardé
si comme les acteurs partant en couille
là parce que j'en ai donné un rôle à
quelqu'un qui part acteur puis de voyons
dont une information jugée conforme time
for king gueule comme l'est le monde
vivent leur vie laisse les gens
travailler comme toi si tu as envie de
toi si tu envie que ce que toi tu fasses
ce soit beau et puis bon puis que toi tu
respectes affellay mais laisse le monde
vivent leur vie c'est quelque chose
terran pas obligé d'aller à la personne
piles usées en pleine phase relatifs lui
parlement qui a passé sa vie à
s'intéresser alors ouais à connaître la
pire être dur avec lui-même parce que
pour vouloir s'améliorer exotiques puis
déguisé d être artiste aiguise son sens
critique tout le temps parce que tout
amélioré de 6 pi vraiment que toi en
tant qu'humoriste
vraiment il faut toujours voir des shows
je trouve pas ça bon peut-être raison
toujours d'autres peines ou pas ce qui
est aiguisé son sens critique puis tu
fais le tri de ce que tu trouves bon pas
bon mais moi je n'étais pas obligé de le
dire alors de la personne c'est
extrêmement bête et moi ça fait 13 ans
fait d'humour j'ai commencé à 19 ans
puis quand ça fait dix ans que tu fais
quelque chose à mener si tu commences à
avoir une perception genre je considère
que je pourrais vraiment des tons si on
m'invitait sur un conseil là pour parler
d'humour puis donner mon expertise le
juge considère que j'en sais assez pour
me considérer comme quelqu'un qui qui
qui peut être les jets ok un expert mais
je pense que j'étais un expert en humour
parce que ça fait trop longtemps que je
suis obsédé par ça mais je veux pas ma
moto flatter weeds un expert mais ça
fait trop longtemps que dans ce milieu
là puis j'ai encore beaucoup à apprendre
mais comme moi je rendu au point où je
sais tellement ce que j'aime tellement
ce que j'aime pas du mot mais je m'en
fous de ce que j'aime ça me dérange pas
que quelqu'un fasse quelque chose que
moi j'aime pas est-ce que j'ai beaucoup
j'ai un respect si sans limites pour
quelqu'un qui fait ce qu'il a à faire
c'est quelqu'un qui se lève le matin
mais qui prend son rêve en main mais qui
va le faire là pour moi ça vaut plus
juste ça ça vaut plus que toute l'oeuvre
que tu peux créer je le fait que tu t'es
levé à chaque matin tu dis je donne une
chance à ce que j'ai à faire pour moi
c'est sale
si comme c'est le vrai t'es con mais sid
vive s'étoffe
c'est dur et rien de facile dans la vie
puis comme accéder à ses rêves c'est
compliqué ça vient avec beaucoup de
blessures ça vient de là des difficultés
de la trahison de la souffrance
j'ai du respect pour n'importe qui qui
fait ce qu'il a à faire
fait que c'est pour ça que je dis je
veux pas être ce monsieur là parce
qu'ils avaient raison moi je pense que
mes toiles
il téléphone c'est pour un gars que
c'est la première fois je pense que
c'est ces gens c'était cool
pour preuve il ya des gens qui me les
ont achetés jo juge pas je peux je pense
pas que je pense que lui avait comme une
amertume que tu vois dans tous les
milieux
surtout mon
on compte peuvent côtoient les milieux
artistiques les milieux artistiques à
beaucoup de gens amer parce qu'ils
pensent qu'ils ont un talent immense
mais ils comprennent pas que si rien
dans la balance
le talent c'est rien le travail c'est
l'intégrité
c est honnête avec le monde c'est c'est
collaborer site s'éduquer apprendre se
relever la résilience
si la résilience ça fait tellement
partie de la game apprendre à se relever
parce que c'est juste des comme je
disais tantôt c'est que des échecs
effectivement ce gala si les gens qui
ont abandonné leurs rêves
c'est eux qui sont méchants c'est eux
qui sait qu'ils vont aller voir les gens
pis on dit misery loves company
quelqu'un qui a abandonné ses rêves il
va aller voir quelqu'un qui va essayer
de lui transmettre sa maladie il va
essayer d'aller brisé son rêve aussi
c'est que des fois ya des gens qui sont
comme un peu comme les gens sont si
méchants sur les réseaux sociaux ou
m'écrire jeu fois qu'une poche de blabla
non il est pas méchant il a abandonné
ses rêves
puis il vaut bien il pas bien pire but
il veut te donner la même maladie mais
comme il est loin de deux mètres de
distance d'être avec les gens qu'ils
sont c'est une maladie abandonner ses
rêves c'est une vraie maladie
ça rend les gens misérables vraiment
vraiment ça les rend ça les rend fâché
salir en traiter comme j'adore l'idée
que peut pas l'idée mais je trouve la
métaphore la poésie j'ai pas le droit de
dire ça c'est le plus grand monstre de
l'histoire de l'humanité
mais le fait qu à adolf hitler voulait
être un artiste pictures piqué gens il
s'est fait ch tchad d'armes son
opportunité puis devenu juste jeu corel
pas exactement les deux affaires mais je
trouve ça fascinant qu'un gars qui
voulait peindre yacht show institut
institutionnaliser le génocide le plus
fort qu top de l'histoire de l'humanité
comme il ya quelque chose là dedans qui
quand il ya un documentaire fascinant
guys que vous devez regarder ciblées
peuvent usap l apocalypse du hockey
c'est pia touya apocalypse staline
hitler la deuxième guerre mondiale
première guerre mondiale la deuxième
guerre mondiale il faut que vous
regardiez s'appuie celui d'hitler aussi
puisque dany regardez c'est charles
beauchesne qui m'a conseillé de l'humour
et charles beauchamp pendant la pandémie
djezzy tout regarder sur la première
guerre mondiale change la paix hitler
est une voie que il se préparer comme il
se préparait comme un comédien alors ses
textes il se préparait comme un comme
lui voulait il voulait faire une
performance il voulait faire une
prestation il était sa poudre
il était sur le crystal meth il ya des
des vidéos de lui qui qu'ils aillent sur
le maître pendant les jeux olympiques
puis comme il peut titre stay y vivait
une vie d'artiste qu'il n'a pas eu trop
chaud ça fait sens que je dis me glock
moi j'en connais beaucoup des artistes
impôts déjà gravi le mont du pavé mais
tout ça pour dire je pense vraiment que
les gens qui ont abandonné le rêve c'est
eux qui sont méchants
c'est lui qui vont aller voir du monde
puis dire des choses qui se disent pas
dire des choses sont horribles ils vont
essayer de transmettre ça aux autres
pays comme j'ai un respect sans limite
pour les gens qui il se réveille le
matin puis qui vivent leur vie comme tel
qu'il l'espère c'est à dire oui merci
infiniment n'est venu nous parler on
dirait que j'avais prévu que c'était la
fin puis que je voulais finir sur une
envolée
je pense que c'est un bon message suite
à tout l'addiction combinent à bord et
un style funk c'est vraiment fait mal au
coeur